meantime copic testing really hasn't
slowed down across the valley and today
a new location for both drive-through
coveted testing and vaccinations is
taking place madison kimbrough is live
there at that new location right in the
middle of the valley it's actually a
different part of the unlv campus
madison
this new location is at unlv's paradise
campus right off of tropicana avenue you
can take a look behind me as you can see
some cars lining up ahead of time
this testing site is so vital for those
in las vegas as it creates a sense of
convenience where people don't even have
to leave their cars and no appointment
is necessary the site has the capacity
to do about 500 tests and 300
vaccinations each night on a first-come
first-served basis while supplies last
moderna pfizer and jansen will all be
available as well as the boosters for
those that are eligible joshua lush with
the clark county fire department shares
how successful the drive-through method
has been since it started a couple
months back gives everybody the
opportunity to actually go get tests get
vaccines i get all the stuff in the
convenience of your own car not getting
out i have to wait lines i'm getting
exposed other people it stays kind of a
little more confined a little nicer i
know they're a lot less stressful being
inside their vehicle it's a little more
comfortable test our self swab pcr test
and results take about 72 hours to
process this new location has replaced
the previous spot at unlv's stan fulton
building
and this testing site off tropicana is
open five days a week that's going to be
5 30 to 10 30 p.m sunday through
thursday reporting live madison
kimbrough live local now